[Music]
JJ Abrams unveiled the cast for the new
Star Wars movie and everyone's
fascinated by this a lot of familiar
names from the first trilogy will be
back for the new film and of course the
Star Wars universe is so huge a lot of
other actors have been cast for all the
new characters that they've come up with
in fact this is a treat some of these
actors are in our audience tonight
dressed in their Star Wars costumes
that's right listen to them they're here
I'd like to take a moment introduce them
to you here are the new Star Wars movie
characters that happened to be in the
audience tonight yeah
[Applause]
exciting news yeah we arranged to have
them all here if you believe that that
was real Jesus footage you'll believe
this let's see there's first there's Jar
Jar bangs is here
here's how is Queen Coachella
there's Darth get off my lawn
[Applause]
bears jobless the hype
there's the protocol droid that
specializes in immature humor I see a
pee-pee
there's Admiral snack bar watch out for
him
and finally our to tattoo is here
[Applause]